let's talk about crazy old Biden in this
crazy old Biden story God for you Biden
again says his son Beau died in Iraq
while catching himself confusing the
Iraq and Ukraine Wars when discussing
what caused worldwide inflation so I
don't know if they have the uh the video
here let's play yeah I think we can play
it no change in the quality of it
just changing the price
and they talk about inflation
you know we're dealing with it for the
whole SEC inflation is a worldwide
problem right now
because of a war in Iraq and the impact
on oil and what Russia is doing I mean
excuse me the war in in Ukraine
and uh think of Iraq because that's when
my son died
the uh because his son did not die in
Iraq he died in a hospital in the United
States correct I believe that's I
believe yeah yeah it was uh uh he had
cancer I believe but it wasn't in Iraq
this is the second time Joe Biden said
this he sounds like he's he's looking
out a window at an old Folk's home he's
like that is
staying on my son you know but if he was
he'd be standing there and be like grass
just thinking about my son he died in a
rock and the nurse would be like that's
right come with me and we'll get you to
bed here's your medicine he'll be like
oh I like my medicine right there he's
not wrong that the inflation is caused
by the war in Iraq though
that's right he accidentally says yeah
he accidentally says something that's
partly true mm-hmm I think the dude
probably is is
he's Beyond medication you know look I
went to uh I was in Gettysburg and one
of the souvenir shops they sold pill
containers really fancy ones like the
little metal heart-shaped and you'd open
it and it was like you put your pills in
it and I'm like wow you know that's for
older people who have to take certain
medications I think Joe Biden's beyond
that like oh yeah you know he's on meds
they gotta have him on uppers and he's
still this bad I've seen videos of THC
consuming amyloid plaque which is the
plaque that grows on the blood vessels
in the brain causes Alzheimer's so
there's evidence that THC consumes that
so you're saying that Joe Biden's got a
rock the ganj if you want to get no bad
dude bro and psilocybin I've heard is
also responsible for neurogenesis the
regrowth of brain cells so there are
alternative treatments that someone
suffering from any kind of cognitive
decline could look at yeah
like wouldn't they like these powerful
Elites know these things and be taking
these drugs or whatever I would hope so
you think so I mean like we hear all
these crazy stories about the blood of
children or whatever like we we know
there have been stories about how they
use foreskin cream on their faces and
how they do blood transfusions with
young people some billionaires even hire
young people to work out of the gym
blood boys that what they're called yeah
I mean that's joke on like Silicon
Valley I think yeah oh yeah it's true
story it's like New York Times or
whatever's reporting is rich people will
hire like 19 year old you know Jim Bros
to do bi-weekly blood transfusions
because it rejuvenates you if that's
true come on Biden's got to be on some
crazy ass experimental treatments to
like fix his brain he's probably doing
that plus a lot more but it's probably
still not helping because of how old he
is I mean didn't he have correct me if
I'm wrong three brain aneurysms I think
it was two
um I I don't know but but that's a
serious deal and this was this was
decades and decades ago yeah uh just a
couple days ago he said that there were
54 states seven days ago he called
Kamala Harris the president of the
United States for the fifth time
um so
again this is not going to stop every
single your body can only do so much so
even if they're juicing them up like at
some point you know they're gonna have
to cut back I mean there is a video the
other like a month or two ago where uh
two videos in the same day and one is
he's very calm very you know is the
video then the second video the same day
uh is the one where he wasn't blinking
and he's like staring at the camera and
he's sort of yelling and it seems like
two different guys right it's like they
maxed them out on the meds and now
they've sort of pulled back because if
they keep going with it every single day
where they have to keep him Juiced up to
get out there he's the president he's
got appointments he's got to be on TV uh
They're Gonna Run them dry he's gonna
drop right then and there which he also
said the other day too by the way I
could drop dead at any minute there's a
set of pets yeah he said that there's
only so much Adderall and adrenochrome a
man could take I mean for goodness sakes
I'm just being fishies this year
obviously uh but but at the end come on
come on like
I I have to believe that there's
ridiculously expensive experimental
treatments that have shown to like
de-age that they have to have access to
oh the metal brain stance in his in his
head I said earlier that the the THC was
dissolving the amyloid plaque and the
blood in the blood vessels actually in
the neurons in the brain that they found
that so yeah I just want to clarify that
it's not the blood vessels it's the
neurons where the plaque grows that
causes Alzheimer's that we know of do
you guys think so it was uh man it's
probably 11 years ago I went to a speech
by Aubry de gray of the sentences
foundation and he was saying that this
is 12 years ago he's like someone who's
younger than 45 today will live to be a
thousand
and he said it's not because we're going
to invent a pill that makes you live to
a thousand it's that as you're getting
older medical technology is advancing
faster than your aging so you're 50 they
invent a cure for macular degeneration
you never experience you know vision
loss then you're 60 you're having heart
troubles but then they've developed a
treatment for that heart ailment so now
your heart's fine now you're 80. and he
was basically saying they're going to
keep finding ways basically you're aging
but science is advancing so fast they're
curing everything and then eventually
you live to be a thousand Rogan's a cool
example if you watch a show a lot you
see them get younger over the years like
what really yeah like probably like five
years ago he was looking pretty rugged
or like four years ago it was probably
just a rough week couple weeks eating a
lot of maybe some junk or something and
then sometimes you'll see it and he
looks like five years younger I mean he
is on it he's on like the life extension
protocol yeah he said he's feeling
better because of the carnivore diet
that he tried where he was only doing
meat and he's like he's not is he still
only doing I don't think so I think he's
doing
um something November where he cuts out
all out alcohol and cigarettes Sober
Sober October excuse me oh yeah yeah
there's another November thing that's
not family friendly to mention here
right I do uh in in
um I I do sober forever
I just don't drink uh I had a sip of
cognac I'm not like you know I'm not
like was it called Tito or whatever like
I'll have a drink I guess if it's if the
the the situation warrants it but I
don't ever get drunk I'm assuming no
drugs no smoking nothing and uh I try to
eat
I've been eating really good over the
past year like the worst thing I've done
is had like traditional desserts maybe
like 12 times in the year
but for the most part it's been like
fresher and fresher Foods eating like a
steak or fish or chicken breast with
vegetables so uh I mean that seems to be
working out I think Joe uh it maybe it's
the NAD because I remember he had that
guy on his show who talked about NAD nma
and Resveratrol you remember it must
have been David Sinclair was that could
have been he's out of Harvard Harvard
scientist I think is that guy and he's
15 but he looks 30. yes that's Sinclair
yeah and his dad also apparently is very
young and his dog I think they were
experimenting on the dogs too and their
dogs are getting life extension really
well what are they doing to the doctor
NAD I believe it's NAD you should talk
to David Sinclair he's the guy I'm gonna
look him up right now yeah yeah I have a
dog that you know would be awesome might
have been nmn nicotine my mononucleotide
what if it what if it is NAD what if
what if the NAD turns out to be some
kind of like you know life extension
serum or something
that's it
nicotine it's derived it's a
nicotinamide I don't know if that has
what kind of relationship that is to
nicotine itself I think it's B vitamins
I think people aren't getting enough
vitamins yeah I I don't think any one of
these therapies makes you younger or
Immortal it just makes you as you would
be if you are maxed out you know what I
mean like most people are probably
dehydrated not getting enough protein
eating too much sugar and not getting
any vitamins
especially with like most modern Foods
having no real nutritional density so
it's like most you're gonna you're gonna
go to McDonald's you're gonna get you
know a burger it's got 40 some odd
percent of your salt intake it's the
bread if you can even call it that so
it's like a really starchy low protein
fatty garbage with like not even good
fat you eat these fast food burgers and
it's like weird petrofats or whatever
trans fats it's not real food yeah all
cooking that's messing everybody up yeah
excellent I will say this have you guys
have you guys noticed that 30 year olds
today look younger than 30 year olds 10
or 20 years ago
people have pointed this out with like
movies you'll be watching a movie and
you'll be like that dude's 30. you look
at 30 year old stay they're like little
kids how old's Tom Holland because he
looks like he's 20. yeah because he's
how old is he he's only 20. yeah but
that's Hollywood maybe okay yeah he's
really young he's looking good for his
age yeah I think when it comes to like
the NAD stuff it's probably just that
there may be a correlation between
people who are interested in doing NAD
or nmn they're also taking vitamins
they're probably also eating healthy
food like you you don't get to the point
where you're doing like some crazy life
extension treatment without having first
been like I'm gonna eat salad and steaks
and chicken breasts I've also found that
the healthier I eat and the more I fast
and things like that when I do introduce
an unhealthy food it hits me harder I
can oh totally dude
gets sore breast is a really Progressive
idea guys but eating right diet and
exercise rest getting good rest you
sound like one of those bigoted crazy
conspiracy theorists there it's a little
bit of hate speech but I thought I'd
just throw it out there just a little
bit they want you fat they want you fat
and sickly and sad well see you look at
the pace that we're going in our life
and everything's sped up so we're eating
more fast food and then that catches up
to us later on and then we're on meds
trying to even out what we ate our whole
life McDonald's and fast food whatever
it is that we would grow up eating and
then we spend the rest of our life
trying to balance that out whereas if we
ate right from the beginning if we all
taught each other to eat right you know
we might not be so sickly when we're
older it's a novel concept I wonder if I
think you brought this up before Ian the
reason that people looked older was all
of the uh what was it the the lead in
the air from gas oh wow did you mention
that or no I was talking about that you
talk about that yeah the development of
lead that was pretty much all throughout
the country that lowered our IQ and uh
development of small children as well
and it was in the air because the cars
driving around so everyone's breathing
in this lead
yeah aging you and making you stupid and
then uh what was there was something you
mentioned Ian I can't remember exactly
what it was
I don't know you mentioned breakfast in
the air I can't remember you mentioned
something else that I was like oh yeah
maybe that's because aging people I
remember when I was just breathing in
the garbage for instance I was like born
in 79 and when I was like in 1990 when I
was 11 or something I would look at a 40
year old and they looked like gray hair
Haggard old 40 was an old person I'm 43
now I look in the mirror and I'm like I
look like I'm [ __ ] 26. it's pardon my
that's mine
I look I look young I don't look like an
old person like not to myself when I
look in the mirror uh I don't I mean but
obviously I cut sugar way back when I
was 28 years old I got I ate this a bag
of kitkats and a bag of Easter egg
chocolate things two bags in one night
and I broke out into this open sore like
over where my pancreas or something I
was like this is sugar did this to me
like my skin broke open I was like I
will die if I do this so I have to stop
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there